at a nature reserve 28 miles north of
where Georgia Williams went missing
police are searching one of a number of
sites in a wide-ranging inquiry across
England Wales and Scotland a 22 year old
man a friend of Georgia's from
Wellington who was arrested at a hotel
in Glasgow has been brought back to
Shropshire to be questioned on suspicion
of murdering the 17 year old police say
they urgently need information about a
vehicle driven by the suspects a lot
concentrated the public's mind please on
a vehicle which is the vehicle I have to
my left here
it's the highest van CX o 6a SV the last
time we denta fired that vehicle was at
5 o'clock in Wrexham North Wales
following that we denta fired the
vehicle at 10:30 p.m. that evening so a
gap of about five and a half hours in
Queensferry Cheshire heading north and
we're also very keen for the public
anyone has information to identify where
that vehicle may have been in that five
and a half hour gap Georgia was last
seen at 7:30 p.m. on Sunday leaving her
family home in Telford Road in
Wellington she was reported missing by
her parents on Tuesday morning soon
after police searched a semi-detached
house in Avondale Road at midday the
silver Toyota van arrived in Glasgow in
the previous 24 hours it had been driven
from Wellington Via Rail in Wales
Chester and Cumbria Friends of Georgia
expressed the feelings of many in this
Shropshire community who've been stunned
at this awful turn of events it's just
complete shock that it's happened to one
of our friends that someone who wouldn't
even harm a fly it's just strange and
weird that it's happened she's a lovely
person to be around like she'd walk into
a room in the room of Brighton with a
smile she's the most intelligent person
on new and clever of pretty just lovely
in every way police work continues at
the home of Jamie Reynolds in Wellington
a man known to Georgia
as the search goes on police will
continuously appeal for the public's
help saying that even the tiniest piece
of information could be the key to
finding Georgia